we gotta talk about california guys we
got we gotta talk about california okay
okay uh so going over here in the in the
conversation about being a chimpanzee
full of snakes
right you know there's an interesting
idea that emerges about uh um
this is we have this story i think
there's 50 snakes in the chimpanzee in
12 leave how many snakes
fox news reports california promotes
dismantling racism and mathematics
guidance in draft for statewide
statewide framework
the concept quote the concept of
mathematics being purely objective
is unequivocally false document states
which you point that
is funny because that itself is an
unequivocal yes it is
so she says the concept of mathematics
being purely objective is unequivocally
false and teaching it is even less so
it goes on to say the document goes on
to say upholding the idea
that there are always right and always
wrong answers perpetuate
objectivity as well as fear of open
conflict
previous statement unequivocally false
following statement we can't say there's
objective truth that's ridiculous are
they going to put this to a vote
yeah oh yeah right so they're going to
count up the numbers and they're gonna
be like this
unequivocally says that it's we're in
favor of this well hold on yeah math
is not that's objective these ideas have
been around for a long time and i think
people just don't realize it the two
plus two plus
well yeah i don't know like yeah just
being bad at math is a normal thing it
happens
no no the purposeful destruct
deconstruction of math when i was
younger i had friends who were going to
these schools where they were learning
this trash
i remember arguing with a friend of mine
when i said we were having an argument
or discussion and i said something like
the only absolute there's like nothing's
absolutely i guess matt except except
math i guess
and then my friend was like that's not
true math is an absolute and i was like
well okay
as far as we can tell math is like our
understanding of the universe and like
for the most part we believe it to be
absolute in many ways
there are probably variables but i guess
and then she's like no
like how do you know two plus two is
four and i was like because if i take
two pens and then two more pens there
will be four pens and i got into an
argument about semantics deconstruction
this is when i was like 16.
so these ideas have been around for a
long time yeah and they've been getting
worse
especially with colleges they're
literally telling people it's on twitter
two plus two equals five
it's insane well here's the thing the
system of mathematics which tells us
that two plus two is four is what allows
for the science to be done
to build this kind of thing and the
camera i'm looking at the microphone i'm
talking into
and which is what allows for the people
watching at home to have access to this
conversation
there is an empirical basis for what we
are talking about here with the rules
and laws of mathematics
the alternate i mean first of all there
is no proposed altered system or
alternate system they just want to
deconstruct what we have now
it's completely ridiculous they have
nothing they're holding an empty sack
the whole point is i can point out that
you're incorrect
but again when they say things like
nothing is objectively true including
mathematics
they're making an objective statement
they're doing it so that
dumb people will be sitting down and
you'll say something like
in order to build a bridge we need you
know this math and they'll go you're
dumb that's not even true math isn't
even real
and then the bridge collapses wasn't
there a story about like a bunch of
feminists who built the bridge and it
collapsed
or something no i mean i don't know it
was it was like a
it was like a girl's school or like all
girls architecture engineering teams
i don't know all i know is like when
it's time to get paid
and someone is like yo i work two hours
this year i worked two hours that day
that's four hours bro and if your
employer was like no it's just three
yeah it depends on how so this is the
thing logic is real
i agree but math is calculated in base
10 in our culture for the most part
so two plus two does equal four but if
you're on a base three
two plus two equals one is on a base
three i don't know well
computers first binary what if they're
on base orange
where their math is based on different
kinds of fruit that's not what if what
if they're what if they're on base
gender and math is not numbers but
genders
do they really think in second grade
they're like by the way base three
we're now in base three guys e and your
r2 is one your argument is predicated
upon someone else having different
parameters that could exist in any place
based on language
is a language it's not it's a way to
describe
consonants no no no no and the different
bases you use is a different language
right and in you're wrong what math
math is not a language we have an
english version of math
what if i said under twa those are
different words a different language
we're still in base ten but i'm
describing mathematical concepts using
different words
i can say flork glop blebo and they
could represent
one two three they're just words to
represent mathematical concepts but
base ten and base two are different
languages to describe
this the same concept
so computers understand one plus one
equals one zero
the point is they work in binary there
are no twos in in computer language well
we all know that one zero represents two
zero so it's obvious
actually this is a really great
representation of constructivism versus
objective reality we're arguing that
most people operating in good faith
understand what you mean we say two plus
two is four your argument ian is
constructivist where you're like well i
can change the definition without
telling you
to subvert the argument i can use a
different language to give you a
different that no one changes changes
and the point i was making earlier which
is basically the point jack made when
he's bringing up your paycheck is
it's really easy to over abstract these
things and go well usually when i see
math just on a paper and i'm told that
these rules exist but i can't actually
be certain
but when you look at what following
these rules produces in the real world
it becomes very clear that math is an
objective reality
right well when people say like how are
we going to communicate with
alien species there's there's like two
different ways math
and music no bullets they come to my
planet
they're catching nine men it's important
to put this in greater context right the
same people that are saying that two
plus two is five are the same people
they're saying
that objective reality is white
supremacy that data is white supremacy
that being on time is white supremacy
that uh being self-reliant is white
supremacy that everything in
america is white supremacy and the
united nations just today our rep
to the united nations said that our
constitution is steeped in white
supremacy
when they say math is white supremacy
that's like
they're they're going salty they're
going minority root it's like one thing
about your culture is white supremacy
you have an argument about it it's
nothing to be like math itself
objective reality yes i think the
concept of zero was invented
or discovered in like i don't know 200
bc or something it was an amazing arabic
guy
yeah yeah actually i always was talking
it was the mayans the mines discovered
it but they were not the first we
found that they had also discovered it
which was very the discovery of zero
with no influence interesting the
discovery is not profound
exactly if they're discovering zero in
two different locations
totally isolated by time and space
without any communication
well which isn't that crazy or also
maybe it's universal
all these cultures independent of one
another have an
understanding of there being two sexes
so i think the up one point i wanna make
is that
two plus two equals one one in base
three but it doesn't equal
eleven the one one you might read that
as eleven but it's not eleven
it's a different language in base orange
two plus two equals
base one two three four five six seven
eight nine and i created my own twelve
and i created
you can translate that mathematically so
right with binary like one zero one is
five but that translates to something
one is one but then one
zero is two one one is three
how many shotgun shells are sitting in
front of me right one zero
in binary and what does that represent
well two in base two or more oh so it's
the exact same thing no matter what you
call
because that's the language i'm
comfortable with right i'm not a
computer a computer wouldn't be able to
tell you that that's true one zero and
two are the same
well it might but one binary machine
wouldn't be able to tell you the
vegetables
you need to understand ian is that
you're talking about the exact same
thing and using different words
yeah different languages no the way
you're failing hold on
i my turn all right i'm sorry jack
they'll we have to pass around
we have to pass around an old style for
the illinois voice and whoever has it
gets to talk
slits perfect uh what you're doing
is translating half of it without
translating the answer
and that's disingenuous if you're gonna
start talking in a different base
then do it all in that base and then
completely translate it back to base 10.
then we'll see they're precisely the
same what you did in your example
sir is that you translated the first two
parts of the equation but didn't
translate the answer
and you left it looking
let's simplify this ian what is this
thing right here in front of me you know
you're saying hold on what is this thing
in front of a 45 apc
i don't know you're wrong it's a
distance you're wrong you're wrong
it's copper you're wrong it's a
cartridge it's all of the above
well you're wrong because ian seems to
think that this object is a bullet it's
actually a cartridge it's the same thing
it's a different word describe the same
thing
so if of them two plus two does equal
four saying two plus two equals five
makes no sense that is wrong and there's
two does not equal five at any base
right so i know
exactly that's the point no that the
argument they have is that
if you have two point four you round
down to ten that's not two oh well
that's that's the argument really
they make is yes 2.4 plus 2.4 is 4 plus
8.
2.4 round if you round is two so you'd
get four
but if you add them together then you'd
round up and get five that's like common
core math
what they're doing is they're changing
the parameters that no one asked for to
create their own answers
the point of which is to deconstruct
your world view and trick you into being
their servant
exactly okay then that i think maybe
there's in city insidiousness too what
what these people are talking about but
i also do believe getting lost in base
10 and thinking that the world exists in
base 10 is dangerous
i'm so hardcore fine with base dude base
10 is what i'm all about because i've
got 10 people call me base 10 coughlin
man that's my nickname
look just because you know this guy and
like say it in different languages
doesn't mean you're not all looking at
the sky
it doesn't mean that the sky is
different you're just speaking different
language and that's all the different
bases are
don't let anyone get confused just a
different language to describe the very
same reality two plus two equals five in
a language where five means four and
four means five how about that boom done
one two three five four six seven eight
i can't get down with two plus two
equals five
it sounds so silly saying that two point
four is not two so
i think fundamentally we agree yeah yeah
and math is racist
it's just it's racist
exists and there's there is objective
math but it is racist okay yeah i mean
look there's another
the accelerationist in me that says go
ahead
no yeah go ahead jack don't go ahead let
them teach them that let's see what
happens
and there will be there will be so this
is the way feminism is going to end
is when a younger generation looks up at
the older generation and says i want
nothing to do with that life
i don't want to be crazy aunt margaret i
don't want to be 55 with cats and no
kids
wishing i had a husband and a family and
lamenting the fact that i decided to
really pursue
that hr job where i got up to second
senior assistant
vice president the same thing could
happen in these circumstances
unfortunately it's sad that these kids
are pawns
exactly these kids these kids will grow
up not knowing math
not being employed and then the kids
behind them will be like yo teach
me the math thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you